[Música]
el agua está prácticamente en todas
partes desde la humedad del suelo y los
casquetes glaciares hasta las células de
nuestro propio cuerpo dependiendo de
factores como localización índice de
grasa edad y sexo el ser humano promedio
es entre 55 y 60% agua al nacer los
bebés tienen incluso más agua son 75%
agua y nadan de manera similar a los
peces
pero ese porcentaje disminuye al 65% en
el primer año qué papel juega el agua en
nuestros cuerpos y en verdad cuánta
necesitamos tomar para mantenernos sanos
el h2o amortigua y lubrica nuestras
articulaciones regula la temperatura y
nutren nuestro cerebro y médula espinal
el agua no está solo en la sangre el
cerebro y el corazón de un adulto es
casi tres cuartos de agua más o menos el
equivalente a la humedad en un plátano
los pulmones se asemejan más a una
manzana con un 83% e incluso los huesos
aparentemente secos son un 31% agua si
somos esencialmente agua y estamos
rodeados de agua porque necesitamos
beber tanto cada día perdemos alrededor
de 2 a 3 litros en sudor orina y
deposiciones e incluso al respirar ya
que estas funciones son necesarias para
sobrevivir
necesitamos compensar la pérdida de
líquidos mantener un nivel de agua
equilibrado es esencial para no
deshidratarnos o sobre hidratarnos ambas
con consecuencias devastadoras para
nuestra salud en general al detectar
niveles bajos de agua sensores en el
hipotálamo del cerebro ordenan liberar
una hormona antidiurética
cuando alcanza los riñones crea
acuaporinas
y canales especiales que permiten a la
sangre absorber y retener más agua
llevando a una orina oscura y
concentrada una elevada deshidratación
puede causar notables descensos del
nivel de energía humor hidratación de la
piel y presión sanguínea así como signos
de deterioro cognitivo un cerebro
deshidratado trabaja más duro para
conseguir lo mismo que un cerebro normal
e incluso puede reducir su tamaño
temporalmente
el consumo excesivo de agua en un
periodo corto de tiempo causa sobre
hidratación o hiponatremia
los atletas suelen ser víctimas de la
sobre hidratación debido a
complicaciones al regular los niveles de
agua en condiciones físicas extremas
mientras que un cerebro deshidratado
aumenta la producción de la hormona
antidiurética 1 sobre hidratado
disminuye o incluso detiene su
liberación en la sangre los electrolitos
de sodio en el cuerpo se diluyen
haciendo que las células se hinchen en
muchos casos los riñones no pueden
continuar con esos niveles de orina
diluida entonces se da una intoxicación
por agua causando posiblemente dolor de
cabeza vómitos y en raras ocasiones
convulsiones o muerte pero eso es una
situación muy extrema en el día a día
normal mantener un sistema hidratado es
fácil de conseguir para los afortunados
de nosotros que tenemos acceso a agua
potable durante mucho tiempo la
sabiduría convencional decía que
debíamos beber ocho vasos al día esa
estimación se ha ido afinando ahora el
consenso es que la cantidad de agua que
necesitamos tomar depende en gran parte
de nuestro peso y entorno
la ingesta diaria recomendada varía
entre 25 a 37 litros para hombres y unos
2 a 27 litros para mujeres un rango que
crece o decrece dependiendo de si
estamos sanos activos mayores o pasamos
calor aunque el agua es el hidratante
más saludable otras bebidas
incluso aquellas con cafeína como el
café y el té también reponen líquidos y
el agua entre las comidas compensa una
quinta parte de nuestra ingesta diaria
de h2o las frutas y los vegetales como
fresas pepinos e incluso el brócoli
están formados por más de un 90% de agua
y pueden suplementar la ingesta mientras
proveen nutrientes valiosos y fibra
y tomar líquidos adecuadamente puede
tener también beneficios a largo plazo
estudios han demostrado que una óptima
hidratación disminuye la probabilidad de
infarto cerebral ayuda a manejar la
diabetes y reduce enormemente el riesgo
de ciertos tipos de cáncer sin importar
que consumir la cantidad correcta de
líquidos hace una gran diferencia en
cómo te sientes piensas y te
desenvuelves día a día
suscríbase a nuestro canal y calme su
sed de conocimientos podría sorprenderlo
todo lo que puede aprender
ah